have you ever bought anything on silk
road
no but i did meet ross albrecht's mom
yeah i had her on here too yeah she was
a very nice woman and i'd love to
reconnect with her because we were on
skype and i was like trying to you know
help her out and but i was i was like 17
so i didn't have [ __ ] but now i have a
platform you know and she's she just
wants her son home and isn't it crazy
the sentence that kid got
they made an example quadruple the
sentence of el chapo ridiculous
absolutely ridiculous or double double
el chapo sentence something insane
it's just it's a little sad man you know
but these this is what happens when you
have when you have people who are kind
of figureheads
and they want to crack down on it you
know
the kingpin charge yeah for some kid
that just created some ebay for crypto
crypto ebay it goes back to that whole
like unintended consequences of what
you're building yeah and then people
start using it for nefarious acts and
you're like but it's with everything
you know it's like people like oh
cryptocurrency like isn't that you know
what people use to buy drugs i remember
somebody told me that at a bar one time
it was a buddy of mine i was like
bro you smoked pot right he's like yeah
it's like what'd you pay your dealer in
it's like cash like yeah the cash is
used for nefarious things like
any medium of exchanges you know so
it's it's it's ridiculous the same thing
happened with you you know um who burner
is
yes he's the yeah he's the guy like the
drug dealer to the
bernabeu's guy the cookies guy cookies
yeah yeah yeah so
luckily he was rich enough at the time
and probably connected enough but he had
like an absolute fiasco of a launch of
some social network that he launched
and it was like the social network
without censorship
and the whole thing like immediately
blew up and he was probably facing the
same sort of charges because now he had
this like free social network with no
moderation and immediately was like
drugs sex trafficking oh yeah just like
the worst of the worst nazi memes not
yeah all that and it was
like he got out of it
but
like he he probably would have been
facing a lot of the stuff that's that's
so crazy though i mean that's the
craziest thing that you make these
people responsible for the users of the
platform right well like you know they
watched so that we could run they they
did the hard things you know even like
charlie shrimp
you know yeah this is another example of
that shout out charlie shroud yeah
like these are the innovators that you
know have paid the price for innovating
in my opinion uh what happened to
charlie shrim
he lives in sarasota yeah awesome guy
yeah he's cool guy uh he was like one of
the first crypto exchanges in the world
yeah and they ended up doing like crazy
volume and because of like i think it
was because of the silk road stuff this
was years ago i i was before my time i
was like 12.
um they got them on a money trance not
having a money transfer license it was
something like that and it was over
something something ridiculous that he
you know when it was brought to his
attention he took action too like there
was no reason for him to get pinched
like that it was it was completely
messed up
and it was it was
and then obviously like i mean
that was at a time where it was like the
equivalent of trading like
tokens on on a video game you know what
i mean like and they're like well you
don't have a money transfer license so
jail
how long did he spend in jail you know
i'm not i'm not sure i'm not wasn't that
long i think it got out like pretty
quickly okay but it was still like i
made a whole documentary about it i
think yeah yeah it's been years since i
like researched this case but we've had
a few interactions briefly
but he's definitely i would i would
consider
absolutely a crypto og yeah you know
like when you talk about like crypto g's
like charlie schramm eric voorhees like
a lot of those guys lost twins man yeah
you know mark zuckerberg made off with
his bag but they uh they got theirs too
man yeah like these are these are these
are yeah their story is crazy right they
were they were in like
ibiza or something when they learned
about
bitcoin or something and hey they had
just got paid their first billion
dollars and they put all of it into
crypto yeah absolutely wild imagine if
it went the other way you know they'd
probably be serving us fries at the
drive-through yeah
but hey man that's the crazy thing about
it though i mean like like
you don't know where it's gonna go and
you set like it's like you buy an nft
today for a hundred thousand dollars it
could be worth a hundred fifty thousand
dollars tomorrow and then you sell it
make 50 grand but then two weeks later
it's worth [ __ ] million dollars and
you'll be like god damn it but are you
mad
kind of
yeah it comes down to convictions so
many opportunities like it's just like
betting
yeah
there's everything in life there's a lot
to that somebody asked me in my comment
section you know do you gamble
we have a story about that
but uh
i'm like no
i'm like no i don't gamble i gamble for
a living
you just have to have the conviction and
belief in this technology and the
projects that you choose and that's
that's really what it is like you have
to stick to it you can't just dip your
toe in and expect to win i mean you can
i mean you can dollar cost average into
bitcoin and have your nice you know two
3x gains over time however you want to
do that in my opinion no financial
advice i always got to say that
um no you don't
i'd like to say it i'd like to say it
i've told you this too like everybody's
hung up on like financial advice and
like i don't want to sound like a dick
someone's like yeah everybody's creators
go this is not financial advice and like
give a whole disclaimer what are they
worried about so so it's one you only
have to worry about that if you are an
actual financial advisor and you're
registered and two if you're blanketing
it on
media to people
it doesn't matter you could you can
literally tell people
buy bitcoin
that's it like but if you're telling it
to a blanketed audiences and it's not
personalized to a single person it's not
financial advice i think it's just one
of those things where like they saw
somebody do it and then everyone just
everybody does it they
you don't want to be that guy you know
that's like
this cryptocurrency is going to this
price and it's going to happen and i'm
certain of this i have my inside sources
this and that and it doesn't happen and
you look like a jackass in front of
everybody is that what richard hart does
no okay
but uh you know this is just like some
of the some of the stuff in the crypto
scene like you know like
everyone's always talking about going to
the moon and this and that i liked it
like i said before bringing it back i
like to do realistic outcomes and
expectations because it's not all
sunshine or roses you know it's not a
rose garden for y'all it's really it's
trial by far dude you're going to come
in here you're going to get your ass
handed to you probably yeah but it's the
only way you're going to learn surprise
your education too many people try to
jump in and just want to get rich
overnight and it's like
you know i have buddies who
like come to me and they're like
i want to trade nfts
and i'm like
you should not be trading nfts no like
start start with like
small investors you can make but if you
if you have the money to buy one of
those apes you can make so much money
flipping them so pretty much every
single ape that's for sale you can look
it was it was bought
20 days earlier for like 50 grand less
well you don't even need that much money
you can put nfts for a couple hundred
bucks man you know like pull up the
invisible friends like the invisible
friends right now
huge i think it's going to be a blue
chip right off the bat looking today uh
to get whitelist on openc uh just look
up invisible friends nft it's not out
yet okay because it's not out yet you
can tell when these nfts are coming and
when they're gonna do well just by just
by like being in the space you'll know
the invisible friends i think yeah seven
to nine ethereum floor price when they
drop
really seven to nine seven to nine to
three those are kind of cool looking
yeah oh that's great seven to nine each
super dope are they animated like this
yeah are you white listed oh no i so you
can actually get white listed if you buy
uh those are sick you have to have four
nfts from the previous collections of
this artist
and it costs and it's like uh 28
thousand dollars so i'm sitting here i'm
looking right now and i'm like do i want
to spend 28 grand to
you to get whitelist to get whitelisted
but like do the rare ones of these holy
[ __ ] i mean so if you get whitelisted
you buy four of his previous nfts you
get one of these for free no you get the
opportunity to pay for the opportunity
and they're gonna start at what
oh i don't know what the price is for
these uh i was looking at them this
morning they're not like overly
expensive they're dope if all of them
are animated like these rotating like
these looping gifts that would be super
sick oh really uh-huh and like dude it's
impossible to get one the only the
public sale will be over in a quarter of
a second and it's gonna go to the people
who pay thirty grand in gas like the the
hay
thirty grand in gas fees it's front
running each other you're whoever's got
the most money to burn wins
you're basically a front run competition
these things i want you to go back and
look at them seven to nineteenth is my
is my thoughts
it's like uh
hate beasts yeah hate beast drops
seventh to nineteenth floor instantly
everybody knew it and everybody was
trying to get in on that white list and
they couldn't what are those worth
seven to nine i think yeah
well they started at six they got to
seven pretty quickly uh and that was
uncommon for an nft project like that
usually after reveal the four prices
tank but they they just
their dis their discord i think had
was
400 000
it was like 400 000 people in their
discord that's four times the size of
ours yeah for one project right that's
not even out by the way and only 8 000
items
so you had 400 000 people competing for
8 000 items
you